Transcriber: Gizem Avcioglu
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
İki şey sonsuzdur.
İnsanlığın aptallığı ve evren.
Fakat ikincisinden emin değilim.
Bu Einstein’ın meşhur sözü.
Bence sonsuz olan bir şey daha var.
O da sanat konuşmalarının sıkıcılığı.
(Gülüşmeler)
İyi bir TED konuşması nasıl olur diye
baktım. İşte insanları güldürün.
Sunum yapın, alıntılar kullanın.
Hatta.
Sunumun farklı renkleri de mevcut.
Evet, bir TED konuşmasından beklenen her
şeyi ilk dakikada verdiğime göre
şimdi gelin rahatlayalım ve
biraz sohbet edelim.
Hayatım sanatla geçti.
Az önce de söylendiği gibi
eğitimim, iş hayatım.
Fakat şimdi siz bunu duyar duymaz
sıkılmaya koşullandınız bile.
Çünkü sanılanın aksine, sanat konuşmaları
pek ilgi çekmiyor, insanları sıkıyor.
Hiç sanat üzerine bir TED konuşması
gördünüz mü milyonlara ulaşan?
Ben baktım, pek yok.
Liseyi konservatuvarda okudum.
Siz hiç on altı yaşında birileriyle Bach,
Shostakovich konuşmayı denediniz mi?
Ben denedim.
Sıkılıyorlar.
Üniversiteden sonra sinema eğitimi aldım
bir de üstüne
ve hayatım, sinema sektöründe geçti
yıllarım.
Daha çok da film festivallerinde sanat
filmi dediğimiz filmleri izleyerek geçti.
Siz hiç festivalde izlediğiniz filmi
birine anlatmayı denediniz mi?
Ben denedim, sıkılıyorlar.
İşte sanat konuşması herkesin ilgisini
çekmiyor elbette ama
Ben burada size sanattan ziyade, başka
şeyler anlatacağım ve baştan uyarayım:
Bu bir sanat konuşması değil.
İlgili olmadığımız alanlardan
sıkılmamız çok normal.
Çünkü bir alanda çok şey tüketip, o alanda
ilerlerseniz zevkiniz de evrimleşiyor.
Yani çok film izlerseniz,
başkalarının sıkıldığı yapımlarda çok
incelikli tatlar bulmaya başlıyorsunuz.
Aynı şey çok okuyanlar, çok resimle
uğraşanlar, çok müzik dinleyenler
için de geçerli.
İlgili olmadığımız alanlarda
bir şey duymak istemiyoruz.
Yüzeysel kalsın istiyoruz.
Zaten dikkat eşiği bu çağda
düşmüş üç saniyeye,
biz de sıkıldığımız şeyleri
kaydırma yapıp, geçiyoruz.
Mesela bazen eşimle maç
izlemeye çalışıyorum.
Hayat boyu az futbol maçı izlemiş
zevkimle, bana göre bir maç 5-0 ise
çok eğlenceli, bol gol var ama eşime dönüp
baktığımda sıkıldığını görüyorum.
Çekişme yok diyor.
Ama mesela maç 0-0.
Ben sıkılıyorum gol yok.
Eşime bakıyorum;
Gergin bir şekilde kilitlenmiş.
Bir dakika konuşma falan diyor bana.
Ve “Çok harika bir maç oluyor.
Çok çekişmeli, kıran kırana” diyor falan.
Neyse ki bu bir sanat konuşması değil
ve sizlere daha çok yapay zeka
ve bizi bekleyen paradigmaları
anlatacağım.
Paradigma değişimini anlatacağım.
Özellikle de yaratıcılığa odaklanacağım.
Yapay zekayla ilgilenmeye başladığımdan
beri, bir yapay zeka sanatçısı olduğumu
duyan insanlar bayağı merakla,
iştahla bir sürü sorular soruyorlar.
Bach’tan, Tarkovsky’den, Beethoven’dan
konuşmaktan çok daha cazip tabii.
Yapay zeka teknolojilerine gönül vermiş
konuşmacılar, insanlar
genellikle halkın korktuğunu,
endişelendiğini anlayıp onları hep
böyle bir yatıştırma derdinde oluyorlar.
İşte yapay zeka meslekleri o kadar da
elinizden almayacak canım, ya da
yapay zeka dünyayı ele geçirmeyecek, basın
sizi öyle robotlarla filan korkutuyor,
şeklinde gönüllere su serpmeye
çalışıyorlar.
Fakat ben bunların hiçbirini
söylemeyeceğim.
Yapay zeka işlerimizi
elimizden alacak mı?
Evet alacak.
Yapay zeka dünyayı ele geçirecek mi?
Evet geçirecek.
Geçirmiş hatta.
Belki Terminatör’deki gibi değil
ama algoritmalar her yerde.
Netflix benim beğenime göre
bana dizi öneriyor.
Google bana kişiselleştirilmiş
reklam gösteriyor.
Telefonum attığım her adımı
datalarına, verilerine kaydediyor.
Ele geçirmiş.
Geçmiş olsun.
Yapay zeka meslekleri yok edecek mi?
Evet, yok edecek.
Ama kuşkusuz yeni meslekler türeyecek.
Yapay zeka yerimizi alacak mı?
Evet alacak.
O yüzden biz de durduğumuz
yeri değiştireceğiz.
Peki biz nerede mi duruyoruz?
Burada, bu beynin sol tarafında duruyoruz.
Hatta durmak ne kelime, yüzyıllardır
orada yaşıyoruz.
Rasyonel, detaycı, daha sol beyin odaklı,
sembolik olarak maskülen yerde duruyoruz.
Hatta o dünyanın
hapishanesindeyiz de diyebiliriz.
Fakat size bir haberim var.
Yapay zeka ve getireceği yenilikler,
değişimler sonrası
geçerli akçe diğer taraf olacak.
Yani sembolik olarak feminen, sübjektif,
sezgisel, bütüncül yaklaşımlar.
Bizi saran bu dünya
genellikle
aslında şu an yapay zekanın
geçeceği dünya.
Yani bu taraf.
Ben burada sembolik olarak maskülen
ve feminen diyorum.
Fakat bu kavramlarla aslında cinsiyeti
tam olarak kastetmiyorum.
Yani kastettiğim şey tam
olarak cinsiyet değil.
Zira hayat böyle ikiye bölünmüş
vaziyette değil.
Buna indirgemeyiz. Gerçek hayat bu iki
lobun arasındaki sürekli iletişimin
oradaki gri alanda geçiyor.
Ve bizi saran görünmez sistemleri
ben anlatabilmek için
kullanıyorum bu kavramları daha çok,
bu sembolleri.
Aslında bu sistemi şöyle düşünebiliriz.
Oksijen gibi, soluyoruz ama göremiyoruz,
dokunamıyoruz.
Orada var ama varlığını unutuyoruz.
Çok sevdiğim bir
David Foster Wallace hikayesi var.
İki genç balık yüzüyorlarmış.
Oradan geçen yaşlı bir balık:
″Selam gençler, su nasıl bugün?″
diye sormuş.
Genç balıklar biraz yüzdükten sonra
bir tanesi öbürüne dönüp
″Su mu? Su da neyin nesi ya?″
diye sormuş.
İşte balıkları saran su misali bizi de
saran böyle görünmez bir sistem var
ve bu sistem daha çok beynin sol lobuna
meyletmiş durumda.
Fakat bu sistemin şöyle bir sorunu var.
Bu sistem taaa endüstri devriminden kalma
ve zamanın ihtiyaçları üzerine kurulmuş
iki yüzyıl önce, hâlâ onu kullanmaktayız.
Hâlâ o var soluduğumuz.
Eğitim sistemine bakarsanız
bizi hep, sol lob odaklı görevlere
hazırladığını görürsünüz.
Keza iş hayatı ve kariyer
basamakları da öyle.
Hep sol, sonuç odaklı.
Picasso’nun bir lafı var;
Her çocuk sanatçı doğar fakat bunu
büyürken koruyabilmek önemlidir diye.
İşte bu sistem, aslında bizim içimizdeki
sanatçıyı, içimizdeki yaratıcılığı
öldürüyor diyelim, köreltiyor diyelim.
Ve bu bizi saran sistem, kadınıyla
erkeğiyle yüzyıllardır soluduğumuz
ve ürettiğimiz bir sistem oldu.
Fakat şimdi artık yenilenme zamanı geldi.
Yeni çağda daha çok sağ lob
odaklı şeyler olacak.
Çünkü bu sistemin sorunları var.
Sadece beyinlerimizde yaşayan
insanlar olduk.
Sadece mantık dünyasında yaşayan
insanlara dönüştük.
Adam Curtis’in söylediği gibi algoritmik
düşünen, robotlaşan insanlara dönüştük.
Halbuki teknolojik gelişimlerin bu kadar
hızlı olduğu, toplumsal dönüşümlerin
bu kadar hızlı olduğu bu çağda bir durup
geriye çekilsek;
Sabitliğin ne kadar zararlı, esnekliğinse
ne kadar yararlı olduğunu göreceğiz.
Çünkü yapay zeka daha çok sol taraftaki
görevleri üzerimizden alacak,
bizden daha iyi yapar
konuma gelecek zamanla.
Ve biz istesek de istemesek de bu tarafa
doğru kaymak zorunda kalacağız.
Bunu yaparken de hızlı adaptasyona, biraz
irrasyonaliteye ve sezgilerimizi
kullanmaya ihtiyacımız olacak.
Bu tarafa geçmeye.
Daha da ötesi, gelecekte telefonunuzdaki
bir yapay zeka aplikasyonu
yıllarca sizin verilerinizi almış ve sizin
verilerinizle hayatınıza dair
kararları sizden daha iyi veriyor
olduğunda, ne yapacağız?
İşte o zaman, içimizdeki sembolik olarak
feminen yönü,
sezgilerimizi ve içgüdülerimizi
yeniden keşfedeceğiz insanoğlu olarak.
Tabii ki dönüşüm sancılı olacak.
Her dönüşüm gibi.
Sancı demişken, son iki yüzyıllık
sanat tarihine bir bakalım.
Hatta “Sanat tarihi” demeyelim,
sıkıcı olmasın.
“Objektiften sübjektife doğru yolculuk”
diyelim.
Hatta gelin biz “İnsanlığın yeniliklerle
olan imtihanının tarihi” diyelim.
1800′lerde Realizm hakimdi.
Gerçek şeyleri gerçekçi resmetmek.
Buna ilk darbeyi Empresyonizm vurdu.
Hani boyaları taşırmayın derler ya,
taşırdılar ve
gerçekçilik gibi objektif bir bakış açısı
yerine sübjektif deneyimi resmettiler.
Sizce insanlar bunu ilk başta
nasıl karşıladı?
Bu sanat değil, bu olsa olsa eskiz.
Daha sonra Dışavurumculuk geldi.
Sanatçılar dediler ki; yeter artık,
dış dünya, dış dünya!
Biz artık içimize
bakmak istiyoruz.
Hislerimizi dışavurmak istiyoruz.
Sizce ilk başta insanlar ne dedi?
Bu sanat değil.
Daha sonra fotoğraf geldi.
Ve fotoğraf teknolojisini tabii ki
biz yıllarca sanattan saymadık.
Fakat fotoğrafın şöyle bir
önemli özelliği var.
Diğer sanat dallarına;
Gerçeklik artık benim işim.
Siz gidin uçun, takılın fantezilerde demiş
oldu ve bunun hemen üzerine Kübizm çıktı.
Kübistler dediler ki
Perspektif mi? Yok ediyoruz biz onu!
Hemen aynı anda o yıllar Dadaizm geldi.
Anlamlı mı? Benim yaptığım şeyin anlamlı
olmasına ihtiyacım yok dedi.
Resmin kalıplarını tamamen yıktı.
Yapım teknikleri dahil.
Sizce bunlar nasıl karşılandılar
ilk başlarda?
Bu sanat değil.
Daha sonra Sürrealistler geldi.
Dediler ki; hisler de geçici,
o da değil!
Biz dediler içimize, rüyalarımıza, bilinç
altımıza bakacağız, onları resmedeceğiz.
Sizce nasıl karşılandılar?
Bu sanat değil.
Ve Realizme, Gerçekçiliğe en büyük
darbeyi Soyut Dışavurumculuk vurdu.
Sanatta somut hiçbir şey bırakmadılar.
Ve sanattaki ifadeyi, anlamı tamamen
yerle bir edip, yıktılar, değiştirdiler.
Kendilerinden sonra gelen postmodern
bütün akımları da çok etkilediler.
Sizce nasıl karşılandılar?
Bu sanat değil.
Bunu benim çocuğum bile çizer,
boyalarla.
Ve günümüze geldiğimizde dijital sanatın
son geldiği noktada,
sanatçılar makinelerle ortak sanat eseri
üretmeye başladılar.
Sizce bu nasıl karşılanacak?
Artık cevabı size bırakıyorum.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bu, ikonik sanatçı Claire Silver’ın
Yapay Zeka Sanatı Sanat Değildir
isimli koleksiyonundan.
Kendisi de çok iyi biliyor
bir dirençle karşılaşacağını ki
koleksiyonuna bu ismi verdi.
Diyeceğim o ki;
Geleneğe karşı çıkan her yeni fikir, her
yeni oluşum her zaman dirençle karşılaşır.
Ve buradaki akımlar gibi kabul
görmesi çok zaman alır.
Bu da benim Vikki Bardot adı altında
yayınladığım Ver Sacrum koleksiyonum.
Burada aslında bir çocuğun hayal gücünün
sorabileceği bir soruyu konsept edindim.
Soru şuydu: Fotoğraflar eskiyor,
analog fotoğraflar gitgide dönüşüm
başkalaşım geçiriyor.
Peki ya içindekiler, içindeki figürler?
Onlar da başkalaşım geçiriyor mu?
Gibi bir soruydu.
Bu soruyla yapay zekaya on binlerce resim
ürettirdim
ve eski fotoğraf estetiğini,
kadın imgesini
ve metamorfozu sorgulayan
bir çalışma oldu.
Yeni dönemde yaratıcılık;
uzmanlaşmak, detaya inmek yerine
bütüncül, sentezlemek ya da remikslemek
gibi yaklaşımlara dönüşecek.
Ve gelecekte yapay zeka mantığı ve
o tip algoritmik meslekleri
bizden daha iyi yapar hale geldiğinde
Dünya daha eğlenceye yönelik bir
dünyaya değişecek
ve tasarım, sanat gibi yaratıcı alanları
içeren bayağı fazla meslek olacak.
Yani sanat yapan.
O tip meslekler çıkacak, işte
Web3 tasarımcısı, Rüya tasarımcısı gibi
daha nice öngöremediğimiz şu an
meslekler çıkacak.
Bunun sonucunda sanatçılar da aslında,
biraz orkestra şefleri gibi, biraz
film yönetmenleri gibi olacaklar.
Ve artık sanat altın çağına tekrardan bir
girecek.
Ve şu an çocukların, “Sanatta para
yok sanatçı olma”
diye duydukları son nesli yaşıyoruz.
On yıl sonra her şey değişirse
hiç şaşırmayın, yani
“İşletme okuyup ne yapacaksın oğlum?
Bir aplikasyonun bile yapabildiği bir
mesleği seçme, git sanatçı ol”
diyebilir aileler çocuklarına.
Hayatta her şey daireseldir.
Ve...
Ben de Einstein’la başladım,
Einstein’la bitirmek istiyorum.
Sezgisel akıl kutsal bir armağandır.
Rasyonel akıl ise sadık bir hizmetkardır.
Hizmetkarı onurlandıran ve kutsal armağanı
unutan bir toplum yarattık.
İşte bu kutsal armağanı unutan toplum
değişmek ve dönüşmek üzere.
Yaşamdaki dişil enerjiyi ve sezgileri
uyandırmakta, sanat ve yaratıcılık
başrolde olacak.
Ve bu gelecekte kadınların rolü
sandığımızdan çok daha öncü
çok daha avantajlı olacak.
Teşekkür ederim.